dernière question sur le chômage on a
aussi appris la volonté du gouvernement
pour les chômeurs en fin de droit de
supprimer laallocation de solidarité
spécifique qui donnit droit à des
trimestres de retraite et euh de
remplacer cela par le RSA pour les
chômeurs en fin de droit c'est quoi
l'idée c'est encore de de durcir les
conditions pour les demandempi l'idée
l'idée c'est que la meilleure la
meilleure émancipation c'est le travail
c'est donc d'accompagner nos concitoyens
vers le travail pour se faire l'idéal
c'est effectivement l'expérimentation
qui a été faite avec France travail qui
va rencontrer nos concitoyens les plus
éloignés qui les aident à régler les
difficultés qui sont les leurs qui les
forment et qui ensuite leur permet
d'entrer dans le
travail il y a dans notre pays des
postes qui ne sont pas pourvus
aujourd'hui les amener vers ces postes
notamment est tout à fait important très
concrètement cela veut dire qu'à la fin
de ce mois nous allons augmenter le
nombre de territoires sur lequel France
travaille travaille aujourd'hui il y
avait 18 expérimentations nous allons
passer à 47 d'ici la fin du mois donc
vous selon vous vous ne durcissez pas
les conditions des demand pour un
demandeur d'emploi ce qu'il cherche à
retourner dans l'emploi notre objectif
c'est de l'accompagner à aller vers
l'emploi c'est la meilleure émancipation
possible pour
lui